foreign
view a first look at what is on the
front pages time then to see what's
making the headlines with peppercura and
Harry Cole welcome to both of you with
us until uh just for midnight so to the
front pages on this critical day
obviously and the New Deal between the
UK and the EU on the Northern Ireland
trade protocol is the lead story for
many including as you can see the eye
the paper also points out that success
hangs on the acceptance by the dup and
uh more Hardline Tory brexiteers
The Daily Mail asks has the Prime
Minister actually achieved The
Impossible
the international edition of the
financial times says the deal eases
post-brexit tensions and hails a new
chapter in relations between Brussels
and London that is also the angle taken
by tomorrow's Guardian PM hails a new
chapter as it says there three years
after Boris Johnson claimed there was an
oven ready deal on Northern Ireland the
Metro says we can finally put the oven
on a number of days later as you can see
there from the top Banner the Belfast
Telegraph headline is make or break a
reference to the complex system which
gives stormwood a say on how EU rules
should apply the loyalist leaning
Belfast newsletter describes it as a
crunch time for unionism
and the national supporting Irish news
says Mr sunac now needs the backing of
unionists to get the deal through while
the Yorkshire Post devotes Its front
page to the death of the first woman
speaker of the commons baroness Betty
boothroat who was born in dewsbury 93
years ago
and finally The Daily Star reporting
that the president of Mexico says a
real-life elf has been captured on
camera in his country
a reminder by scanning the QR code
you'll see on screen during the program
you can check out the front pages of
tomorrow's papers while you watch us
including the star if you have to so
let's go to the political editors then
of the guardian and the Sun pippakura
and Harry Cole let's go straight to the
Daily Mail shall we Harry has Rishi done
the impossible a question for you
uh why is editor once told me that a
headline with a question mark is never a
real story
um so I'm skeptical about that one
um look we don't know too long six long
years now seven years if you include the
referendum we've been arguing and
talking and discussing and writing about
brexit and one thing I learned is that
day one is never a good time to make a
definitive judgment about how so a piece
of paper secured with the EU goes down
and the devil is always in the details
on this thing in the on these things
however I can't remember a deal coming
back from Brussels being greeted so uh
warmly I'd say across the political
divide leaving aside the dep and the
fears of a Tory
um Rebellion appeared to be slightly
melting away tonight because
um a cautious backing I'd give it from
uh senior figures within the
conservative party the dep have said
they're going to go away and look at it
and look study the details which is
about as good as it gets I think with
those guys on on First Impressions and
you can just see from the the tone of
the Prime Minister in the House of
Commons tonight
um he was chipper he was um I haven't
seen him like that in a long time and
sort of he was he was pretty pleased
with himself and he was making the point
that he was the one that got the EU to
do what they've been saying for two
years they would not do which is reopen
that text of the divorce terms and um
there are large concessions that the you
have given
um clearly on the surface of this deal
that are hard for any breakfast here to
escape and any unionist to escape so I
think the governor I'm gonna be pleased
with it with how it's gone today yes
reactions still coming in all the time
we've had
um word from Joe Biden and now just in
the last few minutes in fact from
president macron of France uh he says
the United Kingdom and the European
Union have just reached an agreement on
implementing the post-brexit framework
in Northern Ireland I welcome this
important decision which will preserve
the Good Friday agreement and protect
our European intern the market no doubt
more reaction but the Crux will be what
the Democratic unionist party does what
those key breaks of Tears who are
following the dup do and whether that
matters for ishiz United given he's got
the support of Labor pepper
yes um I mean this was the high stakes
moved by synac but there was also big
wins or there are also big wins there
for him and and one of those is as you
mentioned better relationships with
European Union not just with the block
but also with the individual countries
and already
um the government has hailed things like
for example The Horizon Science Project
which Britain could get back involved in
now and the fact that there might be
better relations with France when it
comes to cooperation and small boats
um again working closer together on
Ukraine and climate change for two of
the to the um issues that uh Ursula
bondale and mentioned today in that
press conference in Windsor so
um there was big wins in terms of
restoring relations also for Rishi
sinaki in the whole sort of party
management side of things for many years
now the conservative parties look
practically ungov ungovernable on brexit
um and has been characterized by splits
um by infighting and frankly with sort
of the Warfare that I think the public
has got really fed up with over the last
six or seven years and so for him to be
able to sort of show that he has some
sort of his capacity to drive something
is called potentially as controversial
as this through his own party could be
seen as a as a big win and and then of
course there's the other element of it
which is that the Promised Me by Boris
Johnson and the conservatives in 2019 to
get brexit done after years of sort of
two and referring over it
um was uh you know it was obviously a
compelling one it helped win him um a
huge majority and so to go into the next
election lots of conservative MPS were
starting to feel a bit anxious about the
fact that this aspect of brexit hasn't
yet been resolved and to go into the
next election and have the labor party
which you mentioned there Anna being
able to turn around and say look they
still haven't got brexit done it's still
not working it was obviously the Boris
Johnson oven baked deal oven ready deal
that brought forward the protocol and
brought that controversial border down
the IRSC and
actual gifts Libra and a big problem for
the conservatives and lots about
Ventures including some really quite you
know firm lifelong brexiteers and have
recognized this and that's where the
timing I think works for sunac on this
he doesn't have the same sort of
backdrop of the party that some of his
predecessors had when it came to
um to getting any brexit deals through
and he's got plenty of his you know this
is the main romp really of the
conservative party recognized that this
has to be seen to be resolved ahead of
the next election the public has no
patience with this anymore so
um so yes so across the board there are
big wins here and that's why he decided
to push on and do this yeah the Daily
Mail chose to show a picture of Ursula
of underlying meeting King Charles the
financial times meanwhile uh with a
picture of Richardson live underline
dear Rishi I mean you know he's Charmed
her clearly don't you think um uh but
obviously he you know she has had to
deal with you know David Davis Lee and
fox Lord Frost Liz trust Boris Johnson
perhaps he is a welcome change who knows
but anyway uh Bros Johnson the male
tells us kept his Counsel on the
proposals does he look churlished now do
you think you know waving the flag for
his Northern Ireland protocol bill which
was always seen as a weapon to hold
against the you know the feet of the
European Union should he not have
bothered with trying to fight for it do
you think um Rishi seem like making
quite clear it's irrelevant now well
it's relevant now because he's got a
deal it wasn't a relevant 48 hours ago
it wasn't relevant a week ago and and
which is in fact multiple times in the
Commons tonight made very clear that he
believes in all their own protocol bill
created the conditions to quote his
words to bring the EU to the table the
negotiations were only possible once
Britain made it pretty clear that uh
they were very serious about walking
away and unilaterally tearing up the
terms of withdrawal agreement which
actually brought the EU into serious
talks yes pausing it before Christmas
meant that the negotiations had room to
grow but there's absolutely no doubt
from the Prime Minister downwards and
don't forget he was a Chancellor sitting
in the cabinet that you know signed off
the the legislation uh under Boris
Johnson to get that ball rolling
um look things happen with the you know
with the EU for years and years and
years they were telling us all these
things were impossible and I actually do
think there's a slight Vindication
tonight for the dep as well in the fact
that actually if you do hold out that
they all the people that are welcoming
these vast movements tonight uh from the
European Union with the same ones saying
that the dep were backwards and looking
and were were Refuge Nixon should just
you know go with the flow and actually
they're holding out has actually and
they're walking away from Stormont has
brought the European Union into the
table just as a northern protocol
Builder the reason that bill was paused
and not scrapped was because actually it
was it was a negotiation tactic and I
think too many people forget in this
country that you know there are two
sides to this negotiation it's too quick
I think to you know especially the
remainers in this country they take it
too quick to automatically take the sort
of European Union's angle on things the
European Union side and silly old
Britain what are we up to and actually
sunac has proven and he was very
gracious today to to to actually point
out that these talks started under Liz
truss and have been going for some time
um you know he was gracious enough to
admit that the we this is this has been
a process and one that has worked so
um I think it's we need to look at these
things in the round rather than simply
assuming that just because he ditched
the bill that's what got the talks going
the bill was the gun on the table that
made the talks happen
I think the whole thing about the
process the process work sorry people I
think we just talked to everybody I was
going to say he praised his predecessors
in the Commons to a lot of Mirth uh on
both sides as we said just got the times
through as well brexit breakthrough soon
executes a deal that grants Britain the
power to veto EU laws with a storm won't
break and just to pick up on the points
that Harry was making you know the dup
feeling Vindicated tonight that the deal
that was delivered to them was rubbish
that you couldn't get the same stuff in
supermarkets in Northern Ireland that
were in Great Britain
um this idea of the green and red
channels you know how that would work
because many elements Jeffrey Donaldson
told us you know both are for Northern
Ireland and for the Republic of Ireland
and this idea of the storm on break
needs agreement from both sides in
Stormont should it research it so what
if the unionists don't like something
but the Republicans do it becomes
irrelevant as well so there aren't
questions aren't there but my point
generally though is is are the dup right
to feel Vindicated tonight pepper do you
think
well look I mean the dup didn't like the
original deal that Boris Johnson struck
and I kind of think slightly we need to
go back a little bit further when we
start praising Rishi sunak he had a very
difficult situation which he has handled
it looks like very well if indeed the
dup do eventually get on board although
they don't need to back it they just
need to not oppose it vehemently at this
point really politically for it to be
able to get through but let's not forget
this was a Tory brexit deal this was a
Boris Johnson Northern Ireland protocol
he's the one that sold the dup out of
the river back in 2019 2020 when it came
to putting that border down the Irish
sea all these MPS that have been banging
on for ages for years about how this
deal isn't good enough back that makes
it withdrawal agreement you know it's
it's I kind of think we're slightly
rewriting history here when we say that
there's nothing to do with end of you
know the delay this could have been
resolved potentially were the political
will there ha it could have been
resolved a couple of years ago but it
wasn't you know so I think
yes as I vote knowledge it was a
difficult situation that Richardson
inherited and he has used he has been
bold enough to face down the rebels to
sort of try and reach agreement with the
European Union to be flexible to win the
dup he deserves credit for that I don't
I'm not denying that but what I do think
is that we just need to be aware of
where this problem started in the first
place and the dup walks the dup walks
out of Stormwind not because of um of uh
you know to sort of put the Northern
Ireland protocol bill on the table but
because they weren't happy with the
protocol Arrangement which Boris Johnson
agreed and signed talking about
rewriting history let's just let's just
let's just let's just go back and
remember what happened in 2019
Parliament seized control of the process
they totally hamstrung the negotiations
they pass a ridiculous surrender act
that basically held gun to the
government's head and said you don't
sign this bill then we're going to
continue need to delay brexit again and
stay in the European Union it was it was
this deal or no deal or stay in the EU
none of those options were particularly
palatable for anyone and yes the dep
were unhappy but there was always going
to be a process brexit was never is as
we we've said so many times in this
program brexit is not a destination it
is a process you've got to accept the
fact that this is actually almost looks
to be something of the plan coming
together in the fact this is why I think
Boris Johnson is going to end up having
to back this this deal even if you like
all of it is because actually what
happened was they made a conscious
decision that there were massive flaws
in the brexit deal the Northern Ireland
protocol being one of them but it was
that or stay in the EU for even longer
and indefinitely and they basically said
we will go back and renegotiate it and
the process of renegotiating it started
almost immediately after the protocol
was implemented uh and here's where we
are and as you said earlier in the
program you know it is about getting
brexit done before the next election and
that's what that agency majority it was
given to the conservative party to do to
get brexit done it was an election four
on giving the government a mandate to do
this yes it's taken longer than anyone
wanted but the idea that it sums out you
know sort of rewriting history suggests
this is all this wasn't part of a sort
of longer term strategy I think is is
slightly unfair yes it's been messy but
they've got there in the end okay I'm
just going to show a few more papers and
no Pippa wants to come back in you will
do shortly um Daily Express first of all
uh PM my brexit deal now takes back
control uh safeguarding sovereignty of
course he said
um Daily Telegraph again picturing him
alongside the EU commission president my
deal is a new way forward a decisive
breakthrough being hailed there and then
the guardian as well p.m hailing a new
chapter in relations with the EU after
the Northern Ireland deal in fact a
meeting possibly with President macro in
the offing we'll talk about more uh more
on that after the break and make or
break that is the headline on the front
page of one of the Northern Ireland
newspapers as well the Belfast Telegraph
back with that in just a moment
[Music]
well welcome back you are watching The
Press preview with me now the political
editor of the guardian papakura and the
political editor of the sum Harry Cole
um Harry I'm afraid I'm going to come to
you again actually because it's your
paper and your your byline on it uh bang
hasn't smashed it uh sausage Wars this
was once described um so I just want to
know what people in Northern Ireland
will see if this is finally enacted this
uh uh Windsor what's it called Windsor
framework or whatever it is um what will
they notice is it just about parcels and
pies and pork sausages what what will
they see
yeah I think the the the the most
noticeable and tangible like feeling of
of separateness I suppose that the the
protocol created was this idea that
actually supermarkets in Northern
Ireland were unable to stock a vast
amount of products
um be that be that sandwiches chilled
Meats was the big contentious one even
seed potatoes you know there was there
was a number of things that were being
held up uh just through the vast
bureaucracy and red tape and paperwork
and customers checks
um but hopefully now once the um once
the uh once that Green Lane is set up as
British is you know slightly
unfortunately worded it today in the
house but the people of Northern Ireland
will be able to enjoy the same Goods as
those in the mainland in their
supermarkets which presumably means no
tomatoes there either
um so it I think that will be a key
issue pets obviously another one drugs
has been a really key issue the fact
that actually there was much more strict
regulation around um around uh
medication uh in in Northern Ireland and
pharmaceutical Goods which actually
gonna be scrapped and also vat uh levels
are going to be set back this is a big
win clawed back out of these European
sphere and bought back under
westminster's tax regime so vat duties
state aid rules you know they sound
technical but it's very unfair that vat
cut on perhaps energy bills in the UK in
the sort of the GB Mainland wouldn't be
able to be passed on in Northern Ireland
so things like that will be a noticeable
difference and that's where the dep need
to stay outside of public opinion
because if they get it wrong and people
actually like this they're going to be
seen as outliers I'm now going to let
people talk because I feel like I've
taken up all the energy yes pets plants
and pork sausages it's quite a list is
it not um and the local newspapers the
Belfast Telegraph the Belfast newsletter
talking about this idea of a crunch time
for unionism just very quickly you know
there are benefits of the internal UK
market and now the internal single
Market paper you know should they should
they accept it do you think the dup and
others
I think they'll be under intense
pressure domestically to do so
um but it is but it is the case that in
the last few weeks and months of them
opposing the protocol so vehemently
there's it's boosted their their core
support their base
um in the polls and there is one strand
of opinion that thinks that actually
that because it benefits them
electorally to do that they might
continue to to take that position or at
least to be sort of critical of it
um
um until until May after which point
they might sort of come on board and get
back into a shower pairing sorry power
sharing situation the big question there
of course though is whether they would
ever be willing to go into a power
sharing agreement with ginseng uh
holding the position of first Minister
um so I don't I think we're not at the
end of the route on that one yet um
there's still a lot of
to come absolutely fascinating too much
to discuss
um luckily you're back in uh in in a few
minutes time Pippa and Harry thank you
both very much lead here's the webinar